hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to but
some of you remember my video game
review of beibei's kids and my video
game review of Blues Brothers on my
volume 2 DVD they suck but needless to
say people loved to see me get tortured
by video games well no more I'm not
doing any more video game reviews but it
doesn't mean that I don't have to not
play video games anymore
I heard of this wonderful little thing
on the internet called let's play this
is where someone just hooks up their
video game to their computer does a
quick run-through of it it just tells
them what they think
well that sounds much easier than just
analyzing and putting an actual review
together as you can imagine just playing
a video game is much easier than having
to review a video game this is gonna be
a walk in the park
so what video game I gonna do today well
let's try Bart's nightmare as we all
know anything with The Simpsons name has
to be gold that is except for the show
right now but anything else connected
with the Simpsons it's always gonna be
fantastic
well except for that and then what to
chop well nevertheless it's got to be a
lot less painful than actually having to
review it let's find out as we do my
very first let's play let's lay this
fucker and I'd be running from this game
too okay look at those graphics and
those incredible it's just like watching
the show action Wow okay that's that's
pretty good okay so what do we we out of
Bart doing his homework okay already I
know this is a work of fiction you never
see part doing this homework okay that's
more like it that's more like the real
part let's see okay he's entering the
twilight zone I guess I don't know why
his homeworks blowing out the window and
he has to go get it
how very existential so what the answers
in his dreams that's that's very strange
but yeah I saw that skip it okay
this must be the beginning to gain them
and that's already at the beginning the
games trying to attack you I like that
just dumps you into purgatory or
whatever don't want that jumping sounds
a great sound okay guess I guess you go
for the authentic damnit get you go for
the homework here alright let's try it
no shit
look how am I suppose to get the
homework right he's trying to run you
over okay yes yeah they do
okay I know how I did that but okay I
have to choose a door okay I guess I'm
going for the blue yes hello oh cool
okay so this is like Bart man flying
around here just that shit okay shit
okay how do i fire things all right
there we go okay so the was that that's
the a button uh fires ease a little am
Ultimo punish it mom fuck with me okay
so you got these a goddamn it fucking
clouds are attacking you how that work
okay so I guess you're fighting the bad
weather uh okay let's see balloons Oh
give me uh yeah okay okay come on I okay
so you're uh
firing these rabbit turds I guess
they're trying to you know you're just
trying to stop these people from him a
good time I guess there's a person uh
hang gliding I'm not sure what he said
but okay okay okay you got to get these
two bitches here uh yes yeah okay I
can't go any higher so I just let them
rain the hell up on me I guess F fuck
I'm like almost down my lesson you know
the life force you're come come come
come attend attended at the detector
detector detector oh my god I'll know
the controls really the only controls on
this are just flying around pushing a
it's about it yeah yeah you died bitches
ha okay uh so you're still flying around
here more weathers trying to kill you
don't know what's up with that shit
chick damn it get down to a skeleton I
suppose on my life force come on come on
dad too tight what's rates are tough
about this is you see how the you know
the rabbit turds they're it's like every
time you fly they just sort of go
backwards I guess they're accounting for
the air it's a very realistic dream I
suppose uh okay boss Boswell we have we
have
we have nothing Oh oh my god the fuck is
it as a chef knows a shit it's a pink
elephant I guess that Barney's right
inside Shekinah clever why do you hate
Barney Barney is awesome why is Bart
trying to kill Barney and is a gala now
we see why
hi oh yeah now a poop to dial diet oh no
he's gonna be something good okay
beef jerky I guess is life or no no
chicken no huh okay
I'll be all right good gun there we go
okay just guess stay away from these
missiles why they trying to shoot a
flying little boy you saw flying little
boy would you try to nuke him I wouldn't
I feel like dude how the fuck you doing
that don't shake his controls are really
hard with these multiple fan mean
they're like Rick cut fuck no killing
you they're like really hard I mean I
guess if you hold it backing by I'm a
little further by me just one of these
isn't gonna do anything all right mr.
Smithers is angry because you tried to
take mr. burns away I guess I don't know
all right detective
oh okay so you'd read it okay good good
good yeah yeah oh yeah you thought okay
shit no I know he's gonna kill me okay
I'm like one of those took out like half
my life force what the hell okay
so you have to kill mr. Smithers here
come on come on come on I'm just gonna
let this ring down a bun you dad okay if
you sort of swing down a bit no where
you going bitch we go okay well I guess
I didn't have to really kill him I just
let him fly off like the pain Zeke our
Diaz that balloon just fart okay so
we're flying around and we're a next row
life I like that okay so alright just
more clouds get clap there's some flying
dog food trying to hit Jen I don't know
what's at the back uh I'm gonna guess
those are bad let me see yeah yeah
that's definitely bad that's okay that
was uh guess I can't blame the game for
that that was really stupid of me okay
oh yeah nice just start me off in the
cloud just start me off on death that
that's very kind of the
am I supposed to fly through these with
these missiles trying to kill me come on
yeah guess I read shit no no no got it
my goggles take off like so much okay
I'm just firing these things like mad
I'm not taking a chance I don't care
what the hell if and I don't care what
my mother comes in I'm doing the fire in
her fucking face this is a nightmare
everything's trying to kill me very
Freudian nightmare when I went down my
mother tries to kill me okay so we fly
down all right I think I got I'm just
gonna fly down shooting this oh she got
nowhere else the point okay okay okay
okay
no no oh hey hey I'm actually don't get
good oh shit why is that why is every
time I say hey I'm doing good something
always has to kill me that that's the
rule comedy I'll be really fucking stars
okay
Hank okay so I know the handler is gonna
come over at some point so I'm gonna
keep really low to the ground so he
doesn't get me enough shit okay I guess
they give up that shit the time Jets
going down what's up with this come on
okay so she can tell by now this levels
gangs really boring you know cuz they do
nothing but fire missiles at little boy
so it's not only boring it's really
cruel and who we got now plain okay yeah
I suppose in fact no coming up no no I
got one life and I can fucking kill me
old man but how am I supposed to see him
coming what am I supposed to do that's
he goes everywhere I go I go up he's
like it goes on say I'm in with homage
what's a double Frank got one more one
more hit gotta make it good gotta make
it good all right yeah
little boys learning little boys learn
how to Tech fuck okay so the barb man
level really sucks there's nothing you
can do about it just fucking sucks okay
yes thank you I have nothing that's a
very kind of reminder glad see I really
need that okay so I'm walking through
it's control so really search out that
then that shabbiha just sources luggage
I guess all right so I'm looking for
another piece of paper come on give me
another piece of it clutter is an arrow
it go the way I was just going thank you
thank you that's a very helpful game
that's uh really give me a lot okay
yes there we go okay which one I'm gonna
do well okay I guess I'm going for the
orange this is cool all right give the
ache good all right so you just sort of
hopping around you know catching
whatever and okay so the moral the game
is try to move and you die it's like why
even play the game alright so I guess
you move around things sort of hop
around with you get this devil fuck here
you pick him ha ha blue devil all right
so you go along your merry way and um
you die that seems to be the theme of
the game you go along and you die
that's that's great ok so I got no more
eggs left hopefully I can find something
really good we got these killer Maggie's
your baby sister's trying to kill you
that is fucked up ha ha ha ha yeah
that's what tough now are ya alright
that no no hey and those the Indiana
Jones level I hope you enjoyed it um I
really fucking hate it is so right I
drop you back in purgatory here that's
nice if I'm right you got get these Z's
somehow so let's see let's try good to
see you have to get the okay that does
nothing thank you oh no no no no ok ok
so this is sort of like real life death
we see a bright light when you're close
to death
close the deck ok I get this bluesy give
me that give it give it no no no I'm
done I'm gonna move this one ok ok yes
ok all right now I have a life where
this is really confusing begin to
collect these Z's in order to keep your
life force up and the longer you get the
thank you just disappear the longer you
get the the Z's like if I forget to like
the other side of the screen like the
farm right side of the screen the longer
the life bar will be to
keys yeah I'm just got stop explaining
this I'm just gonna try and fucking live
because this game is really friggin hard
okay yeah you may also be noticing that
that shoot paper is supposed to take you
next level yeah it doesn't seem to be a
popping up right now it's a little a
little sadistic that way I'm not
entirely sure more good all right okay
so you've got okay so is there like
another arrow that points me where I'm
supposed to go or something cuz this is
really sort of a tedious and the night
yes Tippett on the jumping is impossible
in this game I gotta get another one
easy thing no no no no no no oh I'm
still alive I don't know how that happen
but I'll take it and now I'm dead that's
that was wonderful
thank you gay thank you Dima at that I
feel so privileged that you gave me this
opportunity
game they have my family look at me hate
me and totally want disown me that's
that's wonderful
okay final score your final score is
nothing because you're a failure
oh no that's like what's that supposed
to mean to me it's just numbers you
don't get anything if you get high score
so it's totally pointless well I have a
score there's a score I don't know it's
a score I fuck I'm gonna try it one more
time good try and give you some of the
other levels - there that was fucking
bullshit hopefully I'll actually just
give me the sheet like you did last time
those or even ha ha no I can wait now it
is signing the fucking shopgirl good ok
let's see - a yellow one cuz my skin is
yellow and that just matches so let's
see uh we got a black screen that's
inventive okay good OHA Scratchy okay uh
what do I jump on them or uh uh higher I
guess mash my M F F that's lovely okay
here we go yeah yeah look at
motherfucker motherfucker cool down you
can tap it how the hell expand there you
go ha ha ha ha ha
really that's it that's my god anguish
kill you how they come back like that
makes most I just fucking ok so I guess
it jeez grachi have like a million
cousins
um this shit
fuck your motherfucking mouth you died
don't you die you die you die can
another people take the toilet huh okay
gonna be more shit like I got brilliant
bazooka and then just in our mouth
that's how sex okay okay okay I don't
give a fuck okay I'll get to die ten
time okay okay
go to the right here we go love oh shit
shit no no shit no yeah yeah yeah God
not on the vacuums and the shit never
fucking I know okay okay
Oh die haha pull the shell really a lipo
to give me okay ah
how do you die from a fucking vacuum I
don't get that okay I just sat me down
give me a chance your mother okay let's
just do really that that's gonna eat you
see the shit I had to go against down
there and this this is gonna defeat him
I don't think it's gonna work let's uh
Wow okay i-i've been don't cut hear it
when you lose your weapon okay okay okay
yeah yeah going down biatch don't down
oh oh yeah Mau Mau no no no no give it
up yeah yeah damn out came out you think
I'm fuckin shit before now I'm a fuckin
smoke blower which sounds really lame
and stupid by the inflow smoke your ass
is grass your fucking hair fucking pussy
okay up we go okay okay
Linna oh-oh-oh pitchman no no no you
ain't doing at the end doing nothing man
yeah why is your toy in the Attic I know
that's a very compute again okay so
you're in the Attic you're uh what's
this
okay God seen it not now we're gonna
I'll give us a plunger go that's a
fucking gun don't need to be more guns
and dreams
so okay can't go this way I'm gonna run
this way anymore that shit I shit okay
what's a plunger gun gonna do against a
bazooka okay I guess a lot ah let's see
what else we got
eh okay one shot of those kills you that
is bull ass still got nothing still got
nothing thanks for the reminder game I
blow your fantastic your wonderful
because you're presenting me with so
much fucking at our team and I'm just
really really card to him and join this
and Kim fucking contain it okay
huh so what we got in our our to search
for this sheet of paper then right yeah
my correct I've got a nrz okay gotta
find an RZ because in Bart's head that
somehow saves the world
oh fuck okay this is on talking messy
now every time I get one of these Z's I
have to Scott okay give it give me okay
okay
give me an R am i do I really have no
more but no I just have to got to yeah
okay I'm jumping these that little is
this do it
okay now I'm moonwalking that's great
okay still going back
give me to stop going back with you much
shit okay is that any way to okay just
work this way it's a little confusing
because you have to push left to go
right but okay and I have to push right
to go right all right Andy Izzie I need
air I am friggin dead just going I don't
want Skinner
watch this is he okay gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme
okay still I still the game Hey
Skinner's following me like a pedophile
about my why okay and you know what if I
get that one okay good
said okay so you say okay now you see
that line okay I have to get the Z's
inside that line so whatever you had a
like a second ago where there's only
like a centimeter long you're pretty
screwed and you have to get your Z's
inside the little centimeter line so
that's really stupid huh okay so man has
seen a Matrix Revolutions where he stuck
at that subway stop and he can't get out
no question cuz nobody saw it but it's
like that and it's just as annoying in
fact it's a like if Camrys was here
acting with me oh that's good okay so I
have a suit you can't walk fast because
you know this game was already going a
top notch speed and I had to walk
backwards that's that's phenomenal it's
been like the Tasmanian Devil for
whatever reason every time I get hit I
guess Oh fun
all right may the publish it can help me
out come on come on come on come on look
at your noxee come here you ass what
okay I just won't go that puddle of shit
cuz for some reason I think that's gonna
help me okay that did fucking oh man I
just love it down reaching yes play some
fucking bullshit ass cry fuck ass shit
shit it in giving good another okay
some man suit I'm just looking for a
cheetah homework paper you don't keep
jumps into the sheet of polar paper why
does he just pick it up
and you have that count as your reward
I'd be fine with that I'd be totally
cool make the game
shorter I mean things in the MU like
eight eight sheets of paper I can even
get one I know III get it but then I
travel into it like sensor module
adventurous isn't magical sizzle wins
got some pain of my flask
huh okay what am i awfully that'll um
help close this button okay that was
weird
um but got really bad guy so I like that
uh
kid give me a fucking sheet of paper a
spot to jump into God okay
oh it's going the wrong way the whole
time thank you then that little question
Mike really fucking help me out that's
you got something the same thing yeah
you know you just told me that you get
to tell me the exact same direction I
was going okay okay that that thing what
okay so I just wasted my ultimate
kablooey weapon on nothing that's great
might get you know it's how old you know
if I already walked this way to get to
the shit paper now it's time to go their
way doesn't just figure that you know it
takes just as long to go the other
direction so really you're just you're
just testing my patience before I turn
this game off and that's not the sign of
a good game okay it's hard to jump to
like the jump is always a little bit
that's great now it's kid dignity our
direction that's great that's great what
the fuck my sponsor to give the fuck out
here you look confusing but okay um
alright so still looking with a goddamn
homework oh god he sees trees trees
block like everything how are you
supposed to avoid them no no okay I'm
gonna try one more time give you people
one more time NF Anna I tried hard on
that time I fucking tried harder you
gonna give me Jesus give it just got it
alright got try one more level this
level doesn't give me shit I am done it
wrong this fucking game with a fucking
trash you back you me a sheet of paper
yeah take that Mike or beat the blue
here we go there we go okay give me that
shit give me that shit get me nurse okay
what's on the gravan try the green
radios Gabby this is a fucking
unbelievable I'd better get whoa okay I
like this this this is
okay so you're Bart you're blowing shit
up
captain Tryon destroy that fucker okay
you can't turn around but you can what
max shoots lasers a shoots lasers
patient lasers
so it's pretty very blazer dominated is
it goddamn it
oh I can pour fire okay so I can breathe
by I'm just gonna keep doing me yep
tight fucking home country's yeah okay
so it's almost kinda cool just go around
uh blowing shit up
I like this I can do this uh this is
actually pretty sore goddammit alright
so you're going right just ja okay get
you this okay that's a ha ya fuckin Jets
think your ass you're not a sir you're
fucking shit no god I've done oh no no
okay I guess every time you hit the
power plant that destroys everything
just miss a train got there let me
destroy shit I want to do is tear down
buildings instead of cry okay okay no no
no don't leave me my daughter okay I'm
good try and get that level again cuz I
was a pretty cool level alright
it seems like every time you start this
gate cure every time you start this game
they give this sheet of paper right away
and then every single time you go back
like you have to try a little harder to
get it you look fucking I care if it's a
lunch plate I'm gonna fast forward I'm
the editor watch ah power to fucking
error huh okay here we go
there we go now guy we're gonna do this
Godzilla shut again I'm gonna prove I
know what the fuck I'm doing
yeah you're going down Tokyo York
whatever this is
okay every fucking thing's a yeah you
die you die you're gonna have oh oh you
think it's up oh yeah no significance
fire oh you
ha I don't know what I'm doing there so
it sounds like an Asian gangsters got
him okay okay
focus on the game shine let our focus on
the game blowing shit up
you're angry very angry dinosaur cuz
you're a city and nobody loves you okay
so you'll really long periods of time
got that jet go really long periods of
time enough that active then like a
bajillion things to take you I can never
get that fucking train no okay Oh later
reaction there so your around something
you can do is that you can technically
shoot down at those helicopters like
because you see him coming at the bottom
see if I can do it again
god it's looking fuse because every
button does something so you really have
to know exactly every button dot see
like it you just missed that but excuse
the planes okay no okay ah alright just
see where this level goes I will
complete one of these levels or I will
die shrine which I guess is the purpose
but still no oh my God look how many of
these are coming Ajay you supposed to
hit them all oh wow blew them we've had
to hit like five little telecom ters ah
okay - choo choo choo choo choo choo
choo what's that what's that it's a on
fire okay I don't get it but I'll take
it
I want one ha alright know it and
planning I guess I shrunk me down now
I'm climbing this shit okay okay you can
do this so uh I suppose am I supposed to
eat these people and try you eat this
person hey crew okay let me try to hit
it okay now hey I guess I'm just
climbing a building exciting huh yeah
I'm uh I'm fucking riveted by this
so you're still clients even God we're
done bullshit okay my mom's got help me
all right thank God my mother is trying
to attack me it's really is a Freudian
dream what the hell okay I'm gonna try
on the buttons here
okay so that does that use it on the mom
here no coming your fucking bitch
good okay so I can do this I don't know
what it does by I can do it all the
buttons seem to do that gosh huh how am
I supposed to avoid her she just comes
out and takes a bold screen what you
trying to kill me anyway that's just so
fucking messed up alright so my mother
oh okay come do alright those levels of
pain in the ass are all paying the ass
this games a pain to ask
just let me get to don't know okay kinda
okay majors ha ha ha
I think the pipe that's the secret okay
yeah fuck this noise man I'll go back to
movie reviews next week this is bullshit
I'm never doing another goddamn game
again fuck it fuck it fuck it towards
nightmare you are an anus
Oh